Film Courage: How can a screenwriter create
a hero they want to follow?
Wendy Kram, owner of Wendy’s LA4hire: I
keep saying the same thing but for me you
start with a character with a really strong
emotional want and I feel like we take any
successful film critically acclaimed film,
it’s always a character that has that strong
emotional want whether it’s in…I had mentioned
with THE WRESTLER that my upbringing I have
nothing in common with a wrestler.
MILLION DOLLAR BABY, I don’t have anything
in common with a girl who wants to box, but
boy did she have a want.
And I don’t mean to say that in a…I’m
trying to say the opposite of that so I’m
not trying to make a judgment or be snobby,
I’m saying a great film has a character
with a strong emotional want that no matter
what our upbringing, our race, we can identify
and relate to that character.
The protagonist in Barry Jenkins film MOONLIGHT,
I don’t know what it’s like to grow up
as a young black gay man in Miami but we can
all relate to feeling like an outsider at
some point in our lives, wanting to be accepted,
having very extraordinarily difficult situations
and there was such beauty in the way this
character was able to persevere and overcome
and then it was told structurally and in a
very interesting manner and again there’s
an example where that didn’t follow what
a lot of people would say is the classic Syd
Field or Bob McKee structure.
It was almost like three, not quite Faulkner
but there was a novelistic approach to it.
I think you can break structure when you understand
it to begin with and you’re hitting everything
else really right.
So writing authentic characters, compelling
dialogue, compelling situations and it is
well-structured.
But I do feel it’s like tapping into that
thing that we as humans want and can identify
with and what are universal flaws that a character
may have.